to introduce this idea which actually we
have already talked about before I want
you to think back to this guy why cuz
whatever X very very familiar function
that's what it looks like our friend the
hyperbola right now the hyperbola has
two asymptotes one is horizontal and one
is vertical right so we have a vertical
and a horizontal asymptotes but to get
these we have thought about this idea
about vertical asymptotes they are about
domain and restrictions right because X
is on the denominator X can't be equal
to zero
alright so x equals zero is an asymptote
but when we get towards this idea of the
horizontal asymptote or oblique you
can't ever get there right so you can't
just let me say like let that equal zero
and see what happens okay we get to y
equals zero because we test out very
large values and that shows us how its
behaving as it increases increases
increases and we have already introduced
this notation as X approaches gets
closer and closer to infinity Y
approaches zero but we've been there
forever we'll find that it's approaching
zero from above from above okay and
exactly the same way in the reverse
right as X approaches the other
direction negative infinity it's slope
rushing zero but it's coming from the
other one from below okay now this ID
here that we've got is they said you're
approaching something right the language
of limits takes this right it's right
exactly the same thing in another way
right it says this thing that you're
approaching the thing you're going to
write we're going to rename it this
thing this is the limit okay
a way you can think about it is like
this if I this is the analogy I gave
before if you've got a car right and you
want to see as far as as fast as it can
go right so you're sitting in the
driver's seat you
laying down pedals okay and off it goes
okay and it's gonna get faster and
faster and faster assume you don't break
it or take the foot off okay it's going
to approach it's going to approach some
kind of speed right whatever that number
is going to be now the flip side saying
I approach something I approach early is
to say that's my limit that's as far as
I can go suppose the top speed of my car
is 250 kilometers per hour okay I'm
going to approach that speed I'm gonna
approach I'm gonna get faster faster and
faster faster but from the other angle I
can say that's as far as I'm ever gonna
go that's my limit I will go that far
and no further
okay or I wouldn't even quite get there
right that's the limit of this as it's
behaving so he's how we write this the
new denotation okay this first line I
would say the limit right then short
filament as X approaches write this
underneath kind of like a subscript but
like it's literally underneath oh
whatever X it's actually going somewhere
namely it's going to zero okay it's
going to zero and it's going to stop off
okay in exactly the same way the limit
as X approaches negative infinity of the
same thing whatever X is still gonna be
zero but it's from below okay so I read
this let me say this again it's a little
bit like Logs with this funny way of
actually staying with it the phrase I
read this as the limit as X approaches
infinity of 1 over X is 0 from above the
limit as X approaches infinity of
whatever X is 0 from above okay now I'm
introducing is because asymptotes are
the first place where we get would want
to understand this either you're getting
closer and closer and closer to
something but not getting there so or
you can say it you can't say it equals
in this context right you can only say
it gets closer and closer and closer
okay but here I'm saying okay the thing
that I'm getting closer and closer to
zero so here's my first sort of casual
definition of a limit okay I mean you
put a big box around this okay a limit
is okay all values that a function
approaches
okay that's all you need to understand I
think right like I'm getting closer and
closer and closer to Vic in these cases
I don't actually get there but as you'll
see there are some cases where you can't
just go okay for instance let's think
about extremely simple example y equals
x plus 2 okay now I can graph this graph
this it's not a hard thing to graph
there's my y equals x plus 2 okay
now X to approach infinity and extra
depression a turfy the only reason why I
choose those values it cuz that will
give me a horizontal asymptote but I can
approach any value I like and I can see
what happens to this guy as I approach
that value so for instance I can think
about the limit as X approaches 0
there's a number I can go ahead and
approach that and see what happens right
what happens to X plus 2 as X gets
smaller and smaller and smaller and the
answer is well let's just think about
this way I can approach there's X equal
0 on the y axis right unlike positive
negative et I can approach 0 I could
have put you through two angles contact
right I can come from the right or I can
come from the left okay now thankfully
we have already developed language to
talk about that right from above or from
below so what I can say is well let's
think about coming from the right hand
side from 0 but above okay so here's
where I'm going
that's the direction I'm going in from
above and I'm going towards 0 ok so
what's gonna happen to X plus 2 as I'm
getting closer and closer on to X equal
0 right
why is getting closer and closer to 2
okay closer and closer and closer in
this case there are no discontinuities
there in there asymptotes I can actually
get so - ok so therefore as I can still
this idea of the limit right we first
meet it with your data
in touch because that's where it's
relevant but you don't have to have
asymptotes that think about limits it's
just what a function approaches okay so
yes you should
yes you should now is the thing though
you will note right if I now think from
the other side from below zero so that's
coming from this direction okay um you
can see that if I put it like what
what's happening to this I'm still
approaching the same number I'm still
approaching the same no bar so in some
ways I can keep combine these two right
because wherever you approach zero from
as X approaches zero you come from above
you can come from below it's still gonna
go toward - okay now this is not always
the case this is not always the case for
instance let's think about this guy this
graph of course is 10 X okay so if we
just do regular old tennis okay because
of all these asymptotes flying around
right and all of these plots where there
are breaks in the function okay I have
an asymptote like so to absence of T and
their equations are x equals 90 degrees
and x equals 270 degrees okay that's
what I meant to say okay so now now for
instance in this case let's see what
happens when we think of the limit as X
approaches 1 of these asymptotes right
all of this function hmm okay
now here this hole which way do you come
from this kind of makes a big deal
doesn't it right like if for instance I
come from the right hand side okay from
above 90 degrees so he's like 91 degrees
and nineteen point five degrees in
nineteen point zero five you end on an
unlevel okay what am i approaching as I
get closer and closer
what does tan X approach it's a way down
hoping forever and there's no it's not
like - a thousand or - a million
there's no no stoppage on how far I can
go
so this is approaching negative infinity
but if I come from the other direction
if instead of moving from from this side
and go towards it
left right if I go from the other side
from below okay 10x is not going to they
give infinity it is going towards
infinity okay off it goes okay so
therefore this guy I cannot combine in
the way that this guy does right because
if I just say if I just say as X
approaches 90 is it positive or negative
any well that kinda makes a difference
doesn't it right it's exactly the same
as X approaches zero right
like well which side you wanna come from
because you will get opposite things
okay so this idea of the limit right the
side that you come from that is but
sometimes whichever side you come from
you'll get the same thing and so you
will often depending on the functions
you get you will often get no sign on
this telling you which way to come from